اللاجئون السوريون في تركيا ومنذ اكثر من
عقد طرف مهم في لعبه التدافع السياسي بين
الحكومه التركيه والمعارضه تاره يلوح
الرئيس التركي بورقه اللاجئين بوجه اوروبا
واخرى يقول ان بامكان السوريين العوده
طوعا الى وطنهم على الجانب الاخر يعد اكبر
احزاب المعارضه حزب الشعب الجمهوري بحل
مشكله المهاجرين واللاجئين خلال عامين
معتبرا ان الحكومه التي خلقت المشكله لا
يمكنها حلها هذا الخلاف دفع بعض اللاجئين
للتعبير عن املهم بفوز الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان في الانتخابات بينما اقر سوريون
حاصلون على الجنسيه التركيه بانهم سيصوتون
لاردوغان من بين اللاجئين نيروز وزوجها
عادل اللذين فرامل مدينه عين العرب الى
تركيا عام 2015 وعبر عن املهما بان يحظى
اردوغان بولايه رئاسيه جديده
تركيا وطني الثاني واتمنى فوز اردوغان في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لانه سيساعدنا على
البقاء هنا ولد اطفالنا الاربعه هنا وهم
لا يعرفون سوريا وقد تمارس المعارضه علينا
ضغوطا كي نعود الى سوريا
سوريون اخرون حصلوا على الجنسيه التركيه
عبر الاستثمار او دراسه تخصصات معينه منهم
حسين عتبه الذي سيصوت للمره الاولى كمواطن
تركي واكد ان صوته الانتخابي سيكون
لاردوهان
نتشاطر انا واصدقائي الراي في ملف
اللاجئين وايضا في الملف الاقتصادي لاننا
نرى ما فعله اردوغان من اجل البلد وحتى
موعد الرابع عشر من الشهر الجاري سيكون
ملف اللاجئين السوريين احد اهم موضوعات
الانتخابات الرئاسيه كما كان الحال عام
وسيحبس اللاجئون انفاسهم لمعرفه ما ان
سيتغير ساكن القصر الرئاسي ام لا حسن
جوليد العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات